nominated for his work in Fargo loved
him in Dexter now in life and pieces
just to name a handful of this man's
film and television ography life and
pieces Thursdays at 9:30 p.m. Eastern
Time returns tomorrow night from a
month-long break Colin Hanks
good to see you see above thought you'd
this past week when had Barry Melrose on
the show I know I was I heard it because
you is a die-hard Los Angeles yes yeah
and they are now on a nice little tear
over the last week there aren't a good
little tear made it made some nice
little additions Robby Blake showing up
to the plate a show in Vegas how it's
done yes very excited about that
odd that now Vega sees I gotta I gotta
keep keep an eye on that yeah but that I
mean what a story that is that's
incredible that's insane but you are the
one who informed me I don't remember
when and our vast friendship yeah of the
curse of the 1993 Los Angeles Kings its
Marty McSorley curse it's such a unique
thing and there I think there's so many
shall I just say Americans that are just
completely unaware of it I mean the the
gist of it is Marty McSorley was playing
with an illegal stick and it got pull he
got pulled and it changed the whole
course of the the Stanley Cup Finals
that year it was happened in Game two
Kings at one game won most of your
viewers and listeners already know know
the history but the the the the levels
to which this conspiracy / controversy I
mean it's unreal it was the hundredth
anniversary of the Stanley Cups it was a
hundredth time that it had gone in that
year that year
everyone wanted Maple Leafs verse
Canadians in the final but Canada's
deported son Wayne Gretzky and the Los
Angeles Kings ruin it but then also
there's all these you know these other
little facts the Canadiens team the Habs
that was the last all North American
squad to win a Stanley Cup
so no fins no Swedes no no
actions no nothing none was all North
Americans and I did you know that
problem for years everyone thought oh
they well it's the curse of Marty
McSorley the Kings will never win
another Stanley Cup but then hey you
know we won - thank goodness mhm
and I remember yeah there is right now
mister mister McSorely when the Kings
were going back into the finals for you
know that first Cup run well the second
Cup run yep when they won the first time
there was an interview with him and he's
like yeah you know I still got the stick
it's in a closet somewhere but then when
we won the curse now is that no Canadian
team has won a Stanley Cup since that
not a single one not a single one it's
been 25 years and there's all this talk
about whether the Habs you know brought
the Kings stick box into their dressing
room and measured all the sticks you
know and did the cops turn apply and I I
mean there's all sorts of well because
the Yankee because the the Royals
apparently or the Yankees knew that
George Brett's bat had too much power on
it back in the day yeah when Billy
Martin waited for the proper moment
waited for Brett to hit a home run in
the ninth inning went waited went when
he needed it most busted it out yes that
they knew that so then his fans had to
have known that the stick but other than
just like that's that's an oddly curved
stick just noticing it on the shift on
yeah it's also the the footage of George
Brett's storming out of the dugout right
yeah not a hockey move you will never
see a hockey player do that like sorely
just when uh it got me okay and he just
went into the sin bin like that was it I
guess it's different in the fact you
know when McSorley's got cuts on his
face and he's missing some teeth yeah
you know baseball fights yes guys just
really kind of look at each other and go
I'm gonna hit you yeah you know there's
no more often than not
McSorley doesn't have any stories about
trips to Vegas though the way that
George Brett does right if you if you
know what I'm talking about all of you
kids out there can YouTube that did you
watch the Olympics I did watch the
Olympic a love the Olympics big fan well
you want
the hockey though there's no one else
was watching the hockey I actually liked
the fact that there were no hockey NHL
boomers in it I thought it was great I
thought it was a it was a galvanizing
component to to a lot of the squads and
definitely for the u.s. but then
obviously for for every nation the o AR
the o AO being started on the OE R is
that what they're the Olympic athletes
from Russia
yeah I'm not I'm not big that's the
worst sports moniker since the World
League of American football
I had season tickets to the Sacramento
Serge that's 100 percent say what the
Sacramento surge played in the in the
world League of American football
they won the world bowl in the second
season 90 to 92 and then the league
folded so they were the last two held a
trophy as they were the last Jefferson
Starship played we built this city on
rock and roll halftime to surge one and
then and then they said we can't do this
anyway you know who played on that team
Dave Archer Goldberg the wrestler but oh
that's right Saskatchewan Serge no no
that's Saskatchewan Roughriders
CFL so the Sacramento surge oh but hey
by the way a lot of the players from
this Sacramento surge yes when the
Sacramento gold miners of the Canadian
Football League came to play a lot of
the surge players just moved over I mean
how many segments do we have a
quarterback of the sacrament David
Archer Ben Bennett oh that's 1991 Dave
Archer he was the world bowl to MVP I'm
being told you think to yourself there's
no way I'm gonna talk about the world
League of American football oh yes
with Colin Hanks oh absolutely did I do
that all right I want to take a break
and come back and give the people what
they want alright because again I
mentioned to Brockman that you you you
are concerned that that this is a
potentially played idea because
I asked you about it all the time yes
you've been asked about it as well on
various other tongues but you bring up a
very good point there is always a new
coaching class so there's always new
blood fresh meat whatever you want to
call it so be famed what type of
stepfather with a head coach be yes and
we got a grizzled veteran coming back to
play so I think we got it we got to do
this back in 60 seconds and we got a
great start bench cut for Colin Hanks
life and pieces Thursdays on CBS at 9:30
p.m. Eastern Time
but back in 60 seconds with Colin all
right Colin Hanks back here on the Rich
Eisen show always great when you stop by
sir I always have so much fun Gooden
here good
so again walk everybody through the
genesis of this idea or to me it is a
revelation better than an eye it is one
of the most fun interactive games you
can have well while watching football
okay
I was sitting on the couch one day with
with the old man watching watching some
football and there was they cut to
charlie weis who was the head coach of
we were watching some college football
dr. de notre-dame as a head coach of
Notre Dame and my dad just spread it out
I wonder what kind of stepfather he
would be and thus a game was born and so
now what stepfather was Charlie was he's
the great he's the George Washington
okay the atom in this Garden of Eden
wait I do not recall okay I do he's a
perfect one to destroy a good run yeah
he was a good one he had you know that
sort of flat top that he had he thought
Sean McVeigh when he was named was the
end of this because coaches are now too
young too young yeah I mean it sort of
struck me as he's the kind of guy that
was is not a stepfather he's the kind of
guy that you know is dating your sister
because he's so young but you know I
mean what I like about this game is its
kind of evolving okay you know sometimes
it's just what's their phrase
but there's there's we got some new
things here though I think I think
people will find all right entertain as
you pointed out in the previous segment
what is old is new again yes which by
the way you could say that about
stepdads all throughout Los Angeles you
know you can have more than one step it
is possible
okay so first up is new yet old Raiders
head coach Jon Gruden unbelievable and
we'll put the photograph up for it is to
have him back okay I got two for grood
okay okay I don't know if anyone calls
him that but I knew mama dudes okay so
the first one is he finds out how much
your haircut cost and he goes next time
I'm taking you to my barber but and this
one is a little bit sneaky yeah he's
also the stepdad that has a medical
marijuana prescription but doesn't admit
it he refuses to admit it and no matter
how much you try to call him out on it
he'll say I don't know what you're
talking about I don't know what you're
talking about that's the type of stepdad
John goodness but he gets in that
backyard once the kids go to bed steps
out in that backyard is you know cigar
time it's soon what happens in Vegas
will stay there yeah yeah let's put up
the photograph of the new head coach of
the New York Giants Pat Shermer this is
me a steamer this this one is he was a
little bit hard at first but then it it
actually you realize this is the
stepfather that is not invested so much
in your life but it's incredibly
invested in his real estate business and
he will come in and will just say hey
champ sold two condos today and that's
that's Pat Sherman that's about as deep
that relationship goes you figured him
out better than Giants fans you step
ahead next up this is gonna be a good
one the new head coach of the Tennessee
Titans Mike Vrabel what sort of stuff
Mike's braver here's the weird thing
about Mike Vrabel yes he's only nine
years older than you
your stepdad is now only nine years
older than you not even double digits
that's all that's it he's just nine
years older than you he's the stepdad
who's just and that is the awkwardly
your age just a little bit more gray
you're not really you're really more
disappointed in your mom at that point
that's the now the new head coach of the
Indianapolis Colts Frank Reich this is
gonna be an interesting crank okay
he is the guy yeah that was the junior
business partner - your real dad it's
hilarious and he will say to you over
and over and over again not in a
mean-spirited way he's genuinely trying
to get you in on how funny the irony is
that hey your dad used to be my dad your
dad used to be my boss but now I'm your
boss isn't that funny oh my god what
he's saying
interesting that Frank Reich being one
of the great substitutes of all time
okay
this is gonna be the substitute gonna be
a substitute teacher he could be icy
make a substitute teacher I'd buy that I
don't mind about being the business
partner this one late because we realize
how in the world do we not have math
Patricia radio audience on the Left
we've got the the Boston version of I
mean the shaggy one and now he's cleaned
up this one always cleaned up this is
the one where you the the Patriots
version of him you you go oh oh dear God
what is my mom Mary who is my mom Mary
that's gonna be my stepdad and then the
the Detroit version is on the wedding
day you go maybe it won't be so bad and
that is your only that's like your your
thin straw there that you're grasping on
to so bad it's the cleaned-up version
it's the cleaned-up version I thought
but what I love about this photo yes
still got that pencil behind me and he
does still got that pencil insisting
it's his would your thing be as a coach
oh Jesus we asked the other day today I
told you what mine would be I'd still
wear the whistle during the game yeah
that's my thing let's think I'd just be
hands on the hips all the time all the
time
is it great all the time and then the
last one here Colin yeah technically not
a head coach but he was for about three
hours yes josh mcdaniels what what kind
of stepdad would he be
he's the stepdad that left your mom at
the altar it just don't do you know was
gonna you know it was gonna be your
stepdad and then wasn't very quickly the
you know the the thing the the other one
that I had was he's the personal trainer
he's your mom's personal and after they
get married yeah consistently says great
form honey so whenever wherever he lands
that wherever he lands and you thought
that's gonna be the the step and you
thought this had no more like see it and
the executor I'm given there'll be a
whole new class I think we got a new
tradition
there you go Patricia also the guy who
eats all the leftovers before you get a
chance I like that one yeah I like that
one a lot there you go we're work
shopping let's let's play start bench
cut with Colin all right let's do the
music one first because you know you're
a a music fan of notes man you did
incredible documentary on the history of
Tower Records thank you nozomi uh is a
documentary that everybody needs to to
seek out yep about the band that was
Eagles of Death Metal and the robotic
line that's at the bottle on went all
that awfulness went down at any rate
you're a big music fan of notes I am
alright music please now you have to
start one you have to bench when you
have to cut well I'm ready alright music
festival you'd like to attend Oh
Coachella Lollapalooza Jazz Fest Oh dark
bench cut Oh
Collin Hanks alright so I'm gonna I'm
gonna start the Jazz Fest you to start
jazz we're gonna start jazz fest because
there's something about that whole vibe
of that city I really want to soak all
that in okay and I've heard nothing but
great things I'm gonna bench
Lollapalooza not because of anything
that they've done but I'll get there I
went to the touring one many many moons
ago and loved to go to Chicago Grant
Park but Katara
the Turks visiting Coachella Coachella
yeah I know you've worked hard to get
here put in a lot of time and energy but
I'm afraid we're gonna have to go our
separate ways and I wish you nothing but
the best of luck fantastic
so it's a start of Jazz Fest that's an
upset I don't think any of us that was a
late add on our on our start basic guy
it's a gut feeling it could be horribly
wrong now one of my favorite start bench
cuts that we've done here on the show I
got information from Chris Brockman's
girlfriend about is one of his favorite
movies of all time
okay we played a start bench cut cuz the
fugitive is a remote drop for him okay
future yeah Shawshank Redemption another
remote job yeah but he he didn't start
any of those movies with he started
you've got male twist this is where I
would cue up Tommy Lee Jones saying I
don't care
[Applause]
he started you've gone hell because go
ahead pound the table for you've got
mail pallets alright I want a freshman
year college my mom came to visit
surprise weekend we went inside you've
got mail in the theater know it holds a
special place for me in that God so you
could imagine when we told this to Jeff
Garlin when he was sitting in that chair
a few weeks ago he made a little bit of
hang out then we went to Minnesota yeah
for the Super Bowl
yep Super Bowl MVP League MVP Aaron
Rodgers told him this information first
he said is it it's not even the best tom
hanks meg Ryan movie Oh
which leads us to this stark bench cut
okay start bench cut Joe versus the
volcano mmm Sleepless in Seattle mm-hmm
you've got mail
oh wow an Hanks okay all right well
let's see I am going to I'm gonna start
Sleepless in Seattle because it's it's
it's a it's a goodie I'm gonna I'm gonna
bench you've got mail no wait no no no
no no no sorry this fingers still on the
chest piece me rephrase this this is
finger Scylla Jeff speech I'm gonna
bench Joe versus the volcano because
because it's it's a it's an underrated
gem there was a lot in there okay it was
ahead of its time
okay but I'm sorry you're not gonna
appreciate this you've got mail I know
you worked hard to get to this point you
put in a lot of time and energy but I'm
afraid we're gonna have to go our
separate ways
[Laughter]
your dial-up service has been
disconnected sir lack in all fairness
that would that's probably of all of the
movies of his that I've seen and I have
not seen all of them okay that's the one
I've probably seen the least amount of
time I've seen Joe yeah Joe versus the
volcano more absolutely absolutely which
is not to say it's not good I appreciate
it look I stand by it
seth rogen wrote an entire episode like
an entire arc on an episode of
undeclared all about you've got mad is
that right yeah you wrote an entire yeah
any like never felt very uncomfortable
telling me well you're on drunk history
last night you were kind enough to sit
on the pod with me ensues yeah that
posts today so I'll ask you to retweet
that short last doing that in life and
pieces man
congratulations on very - of this show
thank you man back in the mix starting
again tomorrow night after everybody
taps out think of me Olympics is just
you know everybody all series of until
it's hard you know hey it's hard because
it's only well it's every four years and
you kind of get roped into it and you go
well it's only 18 days I know the next
four years I guess I got a commit to
this well if you can't beat luge put on
a rerun
that's what they say in the business I'm
all about that currently no man yeah oh
yes all about the curling and have been
since since 98 oh I was in Germany and
the only Olympic coverage I could find
was curling so I hopped on that curling
train and have been ever since so this
was like this was wow this was a big one
well Colin Hanks I appreciate you
getting off that curling train to join
us here
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience